having an assignment to write a research
paper may be in the same category as a
dentist telling you that you need a root
canal
neither will be painless but each can be
made less painful when having a positive
attitude and knowing what to expect
the analogy that writing a research
paper is like a marathon
rather than like a sprint race is
frequently used
it's time consuming it doesn't always go
smoothly and can even be painful at
times
but understanding and applying what
needs to be done before
during and after will help you run that
research writing race
this course will help you understand the
writing decisions that will need to be
made
and to anticipate potential barriers so
you can take steps to either avoid
if possible the problem areas or at
least to minimize them
the writing process is emphasized in
every writing course
as with any process enough time needs to
be allowed for each step or stage
the lessons in this course will help you
realize the importance of managing your
time
throughout the entire process also
all three of the pre-writing methods are
discussed and illustrated
and then you'll learn how that
pre-writing stage will help you prepare
a structured outline
we'll look at how you can select a
research-worthy topic
and how to turn that idea into a strong
thesis statement
and then how to select research to
support the thesis
how much how to find it what sources are
credible and how to document those
sources
and finally the course will emphasize
the importance of the revision process
so let's begin on the research paper
journey
why is publishing important
if you're a graduate student you may ask
yourself to do or not to do a phd
what will happen if i follow that track
you have just begun your phd
and wondering how to present your
research right
in which genre should you publish for
starters
you should know that one of the main
tasks of the researcher is to spread
their work and present it to peers
we need to understand academia and how
publishing is a very critical component
for a researcher to advance the
scientific knowledge
publication is a form of expression and
communication
by putting your ideas together in a
resourceful way and publishing it
it allows you to share your results if
scientists kept their results in the lab
there will be no real world progress
publication can also help you feel
stronger about your work by getting
important criticism back from reviewers
who are experts in your field
it also enables you to get familiar with
other academics working on your topic
furthermore if you are thinking about
continuing your academic life
publishing is extremely important you
will be evaluated in terms of number of
publication
and in which kinds of journals you
publish it contributes to determining
salaries
academic position contracts and grants
application
the good things about research is that
there is no one standard way
this means there are many ways to share
your work and to get published depending
on your domain
the main difference between research
papers and other forms of publishing
is that research papers are often
strengthened by facts and statistics
there are different types of scholarly
literature some of which require
original research
also regarded as primary literature and
some that are based on other published
work or known as secondary literature
it is important to have a clear idea
about the different types of articles
that you can publish in journals
this will help you understand the ways
in which you can disseminate your work
and identify what kind of article would
be suitable for your study
the types of publications are different
in different fields
for instance a clinical trial is
possible only in the field of medicine
while an empirical study is more common
in the field of social sciences
it is important to remember that not all
journals publish every kind of article
therefore most journal publishers
provide prospective authors with
accurate and specific guidelines for the
different articles they publish
specifications about the types of
articles published can be found under
the guidelines to authors section on a
journal's website
if you have a target journal in mind you
should check whether it publishes the
kind of manuscript you are planning to
write
some of the possible types of scientific
publications are
original research review article
clinical case study clinical trial
perspective opinion and commentary and
book review
original articles original articles are
papers that detailed studies reporting
original research
and are classified as primary literature
they include hypothesis background study
methods
results interpretation of findings and a
discussion of possible implications
these normally require a significant
investment of time to collect the
primary data and interpret it
conclusively
review article review articles provide a
critical and constructive analysis of
existing published literature in a field
through summary analysis and comparison
often identifying specific gaps or
problems and providing recommendations
for future research
these are considered as secondary
literature since they generally do not
present new data from the author's
experimental work
review articles can be of three types
literature reviews
systematic reviews and meta analyses
review articles can be of varying
lengths depending upon the journal
and subject area
clinical case study clinical case
studies present the details of real
patient cases from medical or clinical
practice
the cases presented are usually those
that contribute significantly to the
existing knowledge on the field
the study is expected to discuss the
signs symptoms
diagnosis and treatment of a disease
clinical case studies require a lot of
practical experience
and may not be a suitable publication
format for early career researchers
clinical trial clinical trials describe
the methodology
implementation and results of controlled
studies usually undertaken with large
patient groups
clinical trials often require practical
work experience
as well as high standards of ethics and
reliability
perspective opinion and commentary
perspective pieces are scholarly reviews
of fundamental concepts
or prevalent ideas in a field these are
usually essays that present a personal
point of view critiquing widespread
notions pertaining to a field
a perspective piece can be a review of a
single concept
or a few related concepts these are
considered as secondary literature
opinion articles present the author's
viewpoint on the interpretation analysis
or methods used in a particular study it
allows the author to comment on the
strength and weakness of a theory or
hypothesis
opinion articles are usually based on
constructive criticism
and should be backed by evidence such
articles promote discussion on current
issues concerning science
commentaries are short articles that
draw attention to or present a criticism
of a previously published article
book or report explaining why it
interested them
and how it might be illuminating for
readers
finally book review book reviews are
published in most academic journals
the aim of a book review is to provide
insight and opinion on recently
published scholarly books
book reviews are a good publication
option for early career researchers as
it allows the researcher to stay abreast
of new literature in the field
while at the same time adding to his
publication list
which is easier to publish an original
research
article or a review article
a review article is generally more
difficult to publish for the simple
reason that it is more difficult
to write a good quality review than a
good quality original research paper
a good review is not just a summary of
the existing literature
it has to be really critical and should
provide a direction or perspective for
future research
this perspective often develops with
maturity and long-standing experience of
working in the field
in fact some of the best reviews come
from well-respected experts in the field
however it also depends on the kind of
review article you are planning to write
for a narrative review or a literature
review expertise and experience is more
important
if you are planning to write a
systematic review you need not be an
expert in the field
if you have a good question and if the
review is properly performed
your article will be of good quality but
then again
a systematic review takes a lot of time
if you are thinking in terms of easy
publication i would say an original
research
article will be a better choice than a
review article
however remember that what matters the
most is the quality of your research
and how will you have presented it in
your manuscript
you